こんにちははじめ社長と金チャイ軽減皆さんのですね今回の企画は声で録音できるじゃ
ないですか
でデイも来てネットを挟んでるんで生の声じゃないかってことは僕が今から自分の声を
録音して録音した声で誰かが話してもう話せるんじゃないかとバレずになっほど安価に
前の曲見たことあるんですけどもう結構さん何か
バレルさんそうですが同じ言葉しか言わないんだよ嫌な女ならないことをレパント力や
してめっちゃ太陽の言葉を準備してもう今から特訓ですよね剣が加速にその音声データ
入れてそれでどんだけ話せるかなぁアルファなるほどッちにターゲット塗ってはマジで
ずっと話せると思うんねちょっとやってみましょう
だけどまずは音声通りでございますいやっ10種類できると思う
は
じゃまず30種類さん娘さんじゃたいけるようなん
いきますもしもしあああああ
まあそういう考え方もあるよねーいやーそれはちょっと違うんじゃないかなああああ
眠いなぁそろそろ寝よっかなぁ
うーんそれはちょっとわかんねーなーお返しでてるのかあぁ机の上にあるかもあ
お父さんとお母さんによろしく弁当箱あー虹かな
マヨ+への
おやすみなさいなーんエジプトだね王元姫が元気か
大丈夫それなんでなんで不思議
殺すぞ[ __ ]や急に電話したくなっちゃってごめんね突然君の声が聞きたくて
あーや別に好きとかじゃないんだからね電技物足りないよ君に会いたい
好きだ好きなんだお休みたいときでエサ
this ルノーとか撮れましたこう結構あると思うんだでプレパーティすごかっ
結構何年にも対応できるようなしたんでまぁさん寿司でやれば多分暴れずに会話できる
かなと思います
6 o 3 o セットバレた瞬間客するようなので頑張れないように頑張っていき
ましょう
では行こう ok 室を3つ増やしましたぁー
急なんだけど
何か質問あります1台当たりますと今気になってることとか
の3つこっちから撮影文を振る薬増やしましたこれで彼曰くちょっとでも円滑になるの
かなと思います
[音楽]
あーさせい
ですかーごめんねかつ膳
急に電話したくなっちゃっ
h 映らぬ
何へ
はぁ
急なんだけど何か質問あります
あの好きなタイプって誰
うーんそれはちょっとわかんねーなー
感が1回わからんのかいいい
王元姫が激化うーん現地 h よそりゃもうね殺すぞ
受け財源や考えすぎるぞ
君の声がー
スタッ
ではわかりですか嘘かはわかりはやん別に好きとかじゃないんだからねとピンがわかる
そこをわかるな
お前しめてるのか feel the 件
ああああお父さんとお母さんによろしく
結核が運休が実は一言もほぼはず電話できるってすごい塗ったっ
[音楽]
すごい欲しいん
結ば see
もしも生
ねっ補填のトリックスター
[音楽]
すっ
回難しい
むしろ生
もしも生
王元客挙句ガンプラずだ
んだったん
会社でしょうか6過ごすいない
送迎車でキターッ
何ですか9
今日元気年金は元気が人気ですよ
何か手伝えることあります
なんかていきたいことですかうん逆に僕に質問ないですか
あー質素すぎる
えっ
ギャングと好きですか
いや別に好きとかじゃないんだからねぇって言うんだよ
ウズできるんだ5名かつ膳
年々大丈夫ですよ日経に電話したくなっちゃって
ping 値は0ですよねあさあ物足りないよ
れたいますかまあつっちゃっといえばラーメンくってるんですよ僕員数ぞ
嘘だッ
ni
yeah yeah
dea
car
ana あああっ